welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and one of my
favorite characters in quantumania is
beb the squidgy little blob obsessed
with Scott's seven holes but some of my
biggest questions after watching Ant-Man
3 were how does vebs ooze work exactly
is he the only creature in the quantum
realm who can make it and are there any
consequences that arise for those who
drink it what is zeb's favorite movie
and why is it 2003's holes based on the
novel by Louis Sachar starring Shia
LaBeouf okay the answer to that last one
is like super obvious but today I'm
gonna use all the Sci-Fi knowledge I
have in me to break down what that is do
in quantumania first of all feb's
character had an absolutely perfect Arc
no notes 13 out of 10. he saw holes he
wanted holes he got holes he saved the
day with those holes his quest for holes
is just so wholesome also he's voiced by
davidismalkian who played Kurt in the
previous two ants voice acting is
incredible because I never would have
matched that silly little voice with
this actor's serious headshots beb is an
original MCU character created by Jeff
loveness just for quantumania so
unfortunately there's nothing about him
to speculate on from Marvel Comics but
real quick I'll give you guys a brief
rundown of this character from ants 3.
after landing in the quantum realm and
separating from Hank Janet and Hill
Scott and Cassie find themselves face to
face with a group of quantum people and
creatures living inside this microscopic
pocket Dimension these Freedom Fighters
dragged Cassie and Scott to a bonfire
where various Freedom Fighters of
different species are chanting in alien
language they hold Scott down wrenches
jaw open and force a jug of red ooze
down his throat after swallowing he's
able to understand each of the beings
around him in perfect English despite
only hearing garbled sounds and strange
dialects before then out pops veb who
explains the uz Scott drink came from
him basically this guy is like the
Kool-Aid Man mixed with the Rosetta
Stone for multiversal languages one of
my first questions after watching this
scene was how does the Ooze work like I
get it you drink it and it makes it so
that you and broccoli man can translate
each other's conversations but how long
does it last how does it translate so
many languages based on the fact that
Janet also drinks a shot of ooze at
Tyler's bar we can assume that the
effects of the Ooze aren't permanent
she's been away from the quantum realm
for quite some time so my guess is that
all of the Ooze is filtered out of her
system at this point it's unlikely that
the Lang Pim Van Dyne family will keep
these powers for very long now that
they're back in regular old 616 and
would need to re-up on the sauce before
trying to speak and understand other
languages again I knew that veb and the
function of his ooze reminded me of
something or someone from Science
Fiction and Fantasy lore so I got down
with some of my favorite media is that
what I wrote I got down with I was
clearly on Nyquil when I wrote this
Jesus Christ that's like a dare
commercial
so I got down with some of my favorite
media to find some answers after
rereading The Hitchhiker's Guide to the
Galaxy and re-watching kibo in the age
of Wonder beasts I also have some
theories about how vebs ooze might
function in The Hitchhiker's Guide to
the Galaxy a human man named Arthur Dent
is saved by an alien named Ford prefect
when Earth is destroyed by Vogons to
create a bypass for The Intergalactic
Super Highway aboard the vogon's ship
Ford shoves a Babelfish in Arthur's ear
so that he can understand the vogon's
gargling language like Scott Lang was
force-fed red ooze that definitely came
out of a weird little guy Arthur Dent is
forced to shove a tiny yellow fish
inside of his ear Douglas Adams borrowed
the idea of the battle fish from the
book of Genesis chapter 11 verses 1-9
which tells the story of the first large
group of people created by God on this
Earth these people were stronger
together because they spoke the same
language and tried to build a tower that
stretched to heaven to make a name for
themselves in fear of being separated
God saw that they were Unstoppable and
decided that he would with them by
scattering them across the globe and
confusing their languages so that no two
smaller groups spoke or understood the
same words Adams is creatured as the
reverse of that it takes the scattered
languages of all life forms across the
Galaxy and makes them understandable for
anyone with a Babelfish The Hitchhiker's
Guide to the Galaxy tells Arthur that is
small yellow leech-like probably the
oddest thing in the universe it feeds on
brainwave energy received not from its
own carrier but from those around it it
absorbs all unconscious mental
frequencies from this brainwave energy
to nourish itself with it then excretes
into the mind of its carrier a
telepathic Matrix formed by combining
the conscious thought frequencies with
nerve signals picked up from the speech
centers of the brain which has supplied
them the Practical upshot of all this is
that if you stick a Babelfish in your
ear you can instantly understand
anything said to you in any form of
language the speech patterns you
actually hear decode the brainwave
Matrix which has been fed into your mind
by your battle fish I think that vebs
ooze Works in a very similar way if the
Ooze is able to absorb the brain waves
of those around it it could then form a
mindscape of thought frequencies that
automatically translates all language in
the drinker's vicinity it actually kind
of reminds me of the device that Cassie
built to map the quantum realm from her
grandpa's lab the machine she built
sends signals to the quantum realm to
collect data and back allowing her to
map and study the QR without ever
setting foot inside of it likewise this
is could be sending neurological signals
to and from the brains of those who
drink it allowing each party to speak
with and understand each other clearly
and a lot of things baby hungry sweaty
curious about what it means to be a tree
but you know what I'm not tired because
I've got Sam
lands products focus on restoring the
body's natural sleep rhythm in a
sustainable clean and non-habit-forming
way there's a lot of sleep aids that
just knock you out but those don't
actually help you wake up rested or
train your body to naturally sleep again
the great thing about sandland is that
they help break the patterns of stress
and anxiety before sleep so that you
eventually won't need any sleep aids
including sand land sand land focuses on
the two key stages of sleep struggle
falling asleep at the beginning of the
night and staying asleep throughout the
night which is why we've got fall asleep
plus and stay asleep plus both
supplements are made from a safe but
highly effective formulation of
l-theanine magnesium citrate valerian
root and CBN CBN is the ingredient in a
hemp plant that has been indicated to
assist the body with sleeping naturally
it's non-habit forming and effective you
just take a tablet or two stay asleep an
hour before bed with a glass of water in
about 15 minutes before you want to fall
asleep do one or two fall asleep tablets
and let them dissolve in your mouth
before swallowing after a couple of
weeks you'll have reset your body's
sleep program and then you can be the
peppy one at your office thanks so much
to sandland for sponsoring this video
click the link in the description and
use promo code new rockstars to get 15
off your sandland purchase like I said a
few moments ago veb also reminds me of
one of the characters from the
incredibly beautiful Animated Series
kippo in the age of wonderbeast it's on
Netflix if you haven't seen it yet I'm
going to be dropping some light season 2
spoilers but it's on Netflix so if you
haven't watched it yet definitely check
it out this dude's name is Tad
Mulholland and he's a collective of
tardigrades AKA water bears who are able
to communicate with your subconscious
mind after you drink him kippo and her
friends first meet him when they
accidentally drink some of his fluids
from a water fountain giving him
unfettered access to their brains at
first Mulholland doesn't realize that
he's hurting people so he joyfully
explains that once they ingest him as
many water bears are able to enter their
mind creating a Dreamscape where he
feeds off of their brain energy until
they die once they help him realize that
giving someone a cool dream isn't a
great exchange for killing them while
Holland changes his ways and decides to
help his new friends with his abilities
instead of hurting them using little
Mulholland cocktails keepo and Co are
able to communicate with some unlikely
mutants by using mulholland's Universal
translating microorganisms as
instantaneous middlemen so okay there's
fictional precedent to stories featuring
organic Universal translators but having
a semi-formed idea of how the Ooze Works
doesn't answer all of my questions is
Deb the only creature in the quantum
realm capable of creating this ooze
there are two Avenues here that are
equally interesting to explore if there
is only one of them in the quantum realm
then we have to wonder how krylar gets
his supply of ooze it's not like the
Freedom Fighters are willingly giving it
over to their opposition so my guess is
that they've either found a way to
create a synthetic version or they have
a dwindling supply of vebs ooze from a
past trade or poor veb got caught and
milked long long ago we're gonna get a
gritty and or level Disney plus series
about his Escape in like phase 14. if
beb isn't the only one of his kind in
the quantum realm however it does make
me wonder if he's part of a larger hive
mind with a unified Network or if he's
more akin to a colony of bacteria I'm
leaning on the ladder as them seems to
have a very individualized personality
and this could explain how both sides
might have oozes with varying politics
but their abilities provide a common
language for the folks of the quantum
realm either way this ooze interestingly
enough could have also been a catalyst
for the separation between the Freedom
Fighters and those working with King The
Hitchhiker's Guide says quote meanwhile
the poor Babelfish by effectively
removing all barriers to communication
between different races and cultures has
caused more and bloodier Wars than
anything else in the history of creation
likewise the Ooze could have potentially
allowed Kang the ability to unite
citizens of the quantum realm to his
cause without previously being able to
speak their various languages once given
this tool it would have made it easier
for him to campaign for his position of
ultimate power in the realm those who
understood and disagreed with King's
ruling could have broken off and formed
the Freedom Fighters while those who
wanted to support him joined his United
ranks allowing him to acquire power and
resources exponentially faster in the
hands of Our Heroes multiversal
interdimensional communication can be an
incredibly helpful tool but in the hands
of any villain that same gift could
easily be weaponized those are just some
of my theories about what that ooze do
but I want to know what you guys think
in the comments follow me on Instagram
and Twitter whitneypuppy follow new
Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you